janosch was ist heute unser thema und
thema heute ist wie reagieren leute wenn
sie so richtig sauer werden
und das weiß ich auch schon immer wissen
wie sind die deutschen daraufhin die
richtig sauer sind los geht's los
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wann waren sie das letzte mal so richtig
sauer vor zwei wochen können sie uns
etwas davon erzählen ja weil die
öffentlichen verkehrsmittel mich wieder
im stich gelassen haben und nicht da ich
meine anschluss für alle passt haben und
das ist er ja es war sehr ärgerlich so
richtig sauer
da muss müssen nach den relativ
glücklicher mensch als mein handy kaputt
gegangen ist glaube ich und da bin ich
gegen die couch gelaufen und dann wenn
mein handy platz kaputt ich hatte das
nicht mal im monat und da war ich
richtig sauer
scheiße ja richtig sauer und sehr sehr
lange her
was war da ist gar nicht wahr wenn wir
das irgendwas auf der arbeit
was mich leicht aufgeregt hat also das
letzte mal als ich richtig sauer war
warf meine eltern weil die haben gerade
große beziehungsprobleme und tragen bis
zu am esstisch aus und dann verhalten
die sich wie so kleine pubertierende
kinder mit zickereien und rum gehampel
und und fällig wieso pubertäre
14-jährigen mehr eltern da sticheln sich
und finden alles doof was der andere
macht und da ich mich so richtig
geärgert dass meine eltern das vor mir
meinen geschwistern in der
weihnachtszeit austragen müssen
wann ich das letzte mal richtig sauer
ist gar nicht so lange her
vor zwei drei wochen sauer ist ganz
schwer die frage gar nicht so richtig
sauer
ich glaube als ich meine kündigung
bekommen habe im august 2001 2002
vielleicht was ist da passiert ich weiß
nicht mehr aber so ungefähr in dem
zeitraum muss es gewesen sein
total und hast du mit ihm geschimpft
kannst du mir ein bisschen davon zeigen
also ich nehme jetzt seine rolle an
schön dann eher wenn ich sauer bin rede
ich glaube ich erst gar nicht viel und
bin ein bisschen nora ignorieren
ja hallo schmolz ja leider nicht um wow
und als nicht begründet war das war
einer probezeit und da sind ein paar
sachen vorgefallen die man hätte anders
lösen können und die firma hat sie
gelöst indem sie mir die kündigung
gegeben hat und wie haben sie die innere
wut die verzweiflung die enttäuschung
artikuliert was haben sie geschimpft
habe ich habe glaube ich draußen einmal
laut gebrüllt und dann ging es wieder
und nie obwohl wir finden doch was
danach ein und so war ich im mauerpark
hier um die ecke und dann kam da
plötzlich ein paar typen an und handel
messer raus geholt und ich musste immer
eine box geben und klar dass da was
passiert hier bei unklar
das war ganz verrückt also die hätten
nicht zugestochen aber es war schon
sie haben dich absolut betont also dass
das lebensbedrohend ja ja sie waren zu
viert und dann auf zweier auf also
million kumpel
und dann hat er eine noch bessere aus
gold und ja das ist nicht mit ist
tatsächlich nicht gut
richtig sauer als person ausgerastet ist
grundlos erzählen sie wie ist das
abgelaufen
naja der der kammer hat internet
ausgemacht weil er zu lange gespielt hat
und das hat richtig ausgerastet richtig
mit wut und so unter wasser weil man
nichts machen konnte so richtig sauer
aber ich glaube keine ahnung wegen
stress in der schule oder so kann ich
mir vorstellen und wie werden sie fertig
mit der wird entweder spreche ich mit
den kollegen da drüber oder mit der
person dies betrifft oder würde das mit
meinen freunden oder im umfeld lösen
können vor zwei wochen als ich meinen
schulterbruch hatte der ronhof mich auf
sich selber ja das tut mir leid und was
haben sie da geschimpft
zu blöd zum laufen umgefallen einfach
gestürzt zu blöd zum laufen wie dumm
kann man sein können wir das quasi kurz
nachspiel
es geht uns ja um die sprache also ich
hab gerade etwas kaputt gemacht in ihre
firma was sagen sie zu mir
warum hast du es kaputt gemacht ist
irgendwas passiert kann ich dir helfen
das gehört sicher waren versuchte sonja
aufzulösen warum das so passiert das
warum das kaputt gegangen ist oder und
sage passiert das ist jeder macht jetzt
keine unbedingt mit absicht fehler muss
irgendwo herkommen
aber ich schaue mir das dann auf alle
jemanden anderen ich war das nicht
wirklich das hat er mitgemacht ich nicht
ich habe das nur angefasst ist kaputt
gegangen aber in wirklichkeit hat dass
jemand anderer kaputt geht dann hole ich
die zweite person auch noch dazu und
fragt was passiert das würde nur zwei
meinungen da muss ich ein urteil ich
sagt hericks wir kündigen ihnen sie sind
nicht genug für unsere firma gut an dem
moment habe ich nicht gebrüllt das war
ja erst als ich draußen war ich ziemlich
entspannt ich glaube ich weiß gar nicht
wo ich mich kriegt gar nicht so schnell
auf aber bestimmt zu hause kennt also
bestimmt noch irgendwie gab es eine
situation wo es missverständnisse gab
und dann hat man sich bestimme
angegiftet aber auch nichts ernsthaftes
man hat sich dann wieder vertragen so
das würde ich sagen war die letzte
situation wo ich recht sauer war
kontakt mit menschen wie gehen sie um
mit der sucht und mit mit dem eher
gering ist sie wäre war vor allen dingen
sind sie schnell dabei zu beschimpfen
und mein schnell beschimpfen werde ich
nicht aber ich würde meinem gegenüber
schon meine meinung sagen also ich würde
zumindest sagen was ich nicht gut finde
also ich würde nicht unbedingt schlucken
und weglaufen sondern wurde dann schon
wenigstens mich dazu äußern
ich glaube ich lasse es an den
schranktüren aus mein schlimmster fall
war ich schrie mein stiefvater statistik
du bist nicht mein vertrag schäme mich
bis heute
ja aber wenn sie wütend sind da muss man
doch wieder wächst glaub ich irgendwie
kommt sofort vielleicht war vor der wahl
möchte mich aber passiert aber wichtig
dass man sich verträgt daher hast du das
letzte mal so richtig sauer so schwierig
wie theo reiß ist nicht weil
mittlerweile schwänze ich alle
schlechten situation irgendwas schief
läuft dann dachte ich ich gehe ich will
damit nicht so ist auch richtig so
haben sie schon jemanden eine runter
gegangen weil sie so sarah nein das habe
ich noch nicht gemacht also ich probier
nicht laut zu werden aber ich sag dann
schon da mal was sollte das und aber
jetzt nicht irgendwie lässig ihn
anschreie oder sie die die person halte
das zu mir sagen bitte einfach als
sprach erfahrungen halter ja sag mal was
sollte das
wenn sie das nächste mal besser
aufpassen so nach dem motto mal sehen
außerdem würde ich über 80 und da darf
man nicht mehr sauer sein
ja und ich bin nicht mal 60 und trotzdem
bin auch programmatisch nicht mehr sauer
bringt nichts auf gut deutsch sagt man
mir gehts alles am arsch vorbei regel
dass auch scheiße
nur denkt man hat davon vor zwei tagen
nämlich noch mal durchspielen sauer auf
sie vor zwei tagen
aber wie man sieht hat es wieder
erledigt und wie werden sie fertig mit
der wut oder mit dem ärgernis unterhält
sich an diesem dialog
der dialog ist alles voller power
speaking es ist immer ein austausch ist
es immer zu sagen was man fühlt zu
schweigen macht alles kaputt
kari und wann warst du das letzte mal so
richtig sauer
gute frage
also gestern nacht als um 4 uhr 50
jemanden feuerwerk gestartet hat auf der
straße bei uns und jetzt hätten gerade
einmal nur das letzte mal richtig sauber
warst und zwar in der sparkasse unter
uns gebohrt wurde und zwar um 6 uhr 50
das ist ja für uns auch mitten in der
nacht was hast du da gemacht ja na ja
ich war zuerst sogar erschrocken weil
das hatte sich so völlig unmöglich
angehört wer würde sowas machen
ja und dann das beste ist janis ist dann
wie ein echter deutsch heruntergegangen
hat sich beschwert und zwar hat aber
nicht freundlich gefragt entschuldigung
können sie bitte ruhiger sein sondern
ich rief ihn an und er schrie schon
er schrie machen sie das sofort leise es
gibt hier eine lärmschutzverordnung
seien sie ruhig oder ich rufe die
polizei und das ist wirklich sehr
deutschen wenn man direkt bei der ersten
konversationen mit der polizei gedroht
danke ja gerne und mit der deutschen
verordnung mit der deutschen
lärmschutzverordnung droht ja wir freuen
uns jetzt auf eure geschichten
wann war das jetzt mal so richtig sauer
wir freuen uns auf eure geschichten und
natürlich könnt ihr auch weiter
deutschland mit uns nämlich als mitglied
dort bekommt ihr zum beispiel übungen
oder auch transkripte und eine vokabel
helfer zu unserem podcast check das mal
aus hier unten und hier geht es unserer
mitglieder seite und bis nächste woche
[Musik]
knopek